and for the rangers it'll be kobe allard
on the mound one lost record is only two
and five but
he is pitched a lot better than his one
loss record solid era
really good strikeout to walk ratio for
a young pitcher
here's the one two and uh that pitch
settles in for a call
third strike a cutter over the outside
part of the plate to get lariano
and so that's how we begin today's
proceedings a strikeout
and here he comes with the 3-2 and this
one is poked off the end of the bat
over on the left side of the infield
where brock holt is stationed at short
he'll make the throw to first in time to
retire olson
so a routine ground ball to short
handled by the third baseman
that caps off a one two three top half
of the first after a happening of play
oakland nothing in texas coming up
chris bassett what can you say he's done
an outstanding job for the athletics
he's been the leader of this staff
making his 19th start
9-2 record he is i mean those first two
starts when he was the opening day
starter for the athletics against the
astros and he gets the
dodgers and then all of a sudden he puts
it all together and he's just done a
tremendous job and
trying to finish out the traditional
first half so two men are out here at
the bottom half of the first and that
brings up adolesce garcia and the 3-2
pitch is swung on line to right piscotty
coming on as they already makes a belt
high catch
that was it right on the button garcia
lines out the rangers go down one two
three
top of the second the is in the ranger
is no score here's jet at 264.
that one is hit well to center eli
white's back eli white at the wall he
leaps up
and it's gone number 10
for jed lowry just out of the reach of
eli white in center field
these take a one-nothing lead straight
away center field for jed lower stay hot
and
he's happy and it was on the
24th that jed got it at the coliseum
and just continues to blister the
baseball
a straight away center field shot by
lowry
in the top of the second in arlington
and jed continues
red hot and the ace take a one-nothing
lead
he's not just sneaking them down the
line he's driving them to dead
center but the ace have the early lead
sean murphy
murphy homered yesterday
they have homered again and that baby's
gone
second day in a row the a's go back to
back
in the second inning can you talk about
a nice easy swing
on a breaking pitch and you know
there's a reason that bob melvin wants
him in the lineup
and his power his 12th home run this
breaking ball and just an easy swing
and another line drive yesterday
ball that he hit with the second deck
and martin
like white jumped but no chance so
number 12 for murphy
and the a's lead two to nothing two
nothing is the rangers
have low hicks and doll against bassett
o2 pitch is swung
on and miss and that's strike three so
low strikes out here's big
john hicks he's playing to pull in the
pitches of curves swung on and missed
some of back-to-back strikeouts go to
the top of the fourth eddie man olsen
trying to get himself ready for the home
run derby and joey gallo had a little
home run derby
practice yesterday after regular batting
practice
center field hit pretty well white
back white at the wall and that baby's
goal
another home run for matt olsen against
a left-handed pitcher
and that's why matt olsen
what does he say he's going to try to
pull everything tomorrow night and
the home run derby this is the reason he
doesn't have to
that was a little cut fastball and this
is left of center
and white just ran out of room that's a
no doubt and eli white went as far as he
could go and really had no chance at all
to get to the ball as it carried well
past his reach
and the azad on here in the fourth
inning against allard lead off single
here in the bottom of the fifth inning
and it brings up
nick solo i'm gonna do it anyway let's
never stop this
live shot in the gap off the bat of nick
solak and it is fun to watch david dahl
as he scores
easily on that double off the bat of
nick solak and the rangers are on the
board they now trail at three to one
well that was a well struck ball by nick
zolac
you can see the pitch looks like a
cutter and it
spins and never really reaches the
location that bassett wanted it to go
and solace jumped on it belt high out
over the plate
ripped it into the gap in right center
field david dahl sprinting around the
bases scores easily
and the rangers sneaking right back into
this ball game matt olson checks in with
one out in the sixth
yeah that's a line drive and that baby's
gone
well eric if you're throwing the uh home
run derby tomorrow just take note
throw it right where this pitch is so
matt olson
finishing the first half off in style a
two-homer game he's got 23 now
that was a high line drop and it gives
the a's a 4-1 lead
one-and-one delivery is swung on and hit
down the right field side in the corner
long run for scotty
and he dives he makes a phenomenal catch
and he picked up chalk and literally
diving right on the foul line and right
field into the corner
in a full out dive and he took it right
off the dirt right off the track
what a play by biscotti for the second
out
just a brilliant full out dive and kept
his eye on the ball and
biscotti made a great catch it's just
great to see him making the
contributions we've seen him in the past
do
on both sides of the ball we go to the
top of the eighth inning
and the a's are leading it four to one
right now
one hopper hit through isaiah kind of
falefa front throw over to first and
there's the first out here in the eighth
inning oh no wait a minute
they are saying that nate lowe was off
the back
i never even looked i've already written
it down to my scorebook i never saw what
happened
don wakamatsu is on the phone they'll
check whether or not they're going to
replay this
and he gives the sign to chris woodward
they are indeed
going to challenge this play bruce
strechman over at first base
well the heel might be off it's hard to
tell if the toes are off or not
it sure looks like he's pushing up
against the base
and it sure looked like bruce dreckman
had a great view
look at his eyes he's staring right at
the base
right at the foot and makes the call
so in his mind what he saw was you
weren't on the base
and he indeed will be ruled safe
chris woodward is not too happy about
this at all
and you can see why chris would be
frustrated on such a routine play
and it's going to go down as an error
against nate lowe the ranger fans
obviously not happy about it bruce
dreckman's sticking to his gun so chris
woodward stays in this game
not happy about that call at all lou
trevino takes over on the mound
looking for a save trevino's for 15 in
save
opportunities so far this year first
pitch to high
any time hits with deep to center field
loriano's back
he's got room makes the catch and that's
the ball game
time put a little scare into all of us
but yes
comes up just a little bit short and the
a's
win the series in arlington